THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP DELIVERING ON
ANOTHER ONE OF HIS CAMPAIGN
PROMISES, CALLING FOR TOUGHER
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
THE PRESIDENT HOSTED A
ROUNDTABLE WITH POLICE,
CONGRESSMEN AND LOCAL LEADERS ON
LONG ISLAND, NEW YORK, AN AREA
HIT HARD BY THE MURDEROUS MS-13
GANG.
>> WE ARE HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS
THE MENACE OF MS-13.
IT'S A MENACE.
THEY EXPLOITED THE LOOPHOLES IN
OUR LAWS TO ENTER THE COUNTRY AS
UNACCOMPANIED ALIEN MINORS.
THEY LOOKED SO INNOCENT.
THEY ARE NOT INNOCENT.
CRIPPLING LOOPHOLES IN OUR LAWS
HAVE ENABLED MS-13 GANG MEMBERS
AND OTHER CRIMINALS TO
INFILTRATE OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS
REFUSED TO CLOSE THESE LOOPHOLES
REFUSED TO CLOSE THESE LOOPHOLE
LOOPHOLES.
INCLUDING THE DISGRACEFUL
PRACTICE KNOWN AS CATCH AND
RELEASE.
35 THE PRESIDENT CALLING OUT
DEMOCRATS WHO HE SAYS CAME TO
THE DEFENSE OF MS-13 GANG
MEMBERS AFTER HE CALLED THEM
ANIMALS.
>> I NOTICED RECENTLY WHERE
DEMOCRATS NANCY PELOSI AS AN
EXAMPLE ARE TRYING TO DEFEND
MS-13 GANG MEMBERS.
I CALL THEM ANIMALS.
AND I WAS MET WITH REBUKE.
THEY SAID THEY ARE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT PEOPLE.
THESE ARE ANIMALS.
AND WE HAVE TO BE VERY, VERY
TOUGH.
>> Kimberly: MEANWHILE, A
LOCAL POLICE COMMISSIONER
SOUNDING THE ALARM ON JUST HOW
DANGEROUS THESE GANGS ARE
COMMUNITIES.
>> WE NEED HELP.
WHEN WE HAVE 40% OF OUR
HOMICIDES ON MS-13 RELATED AND
OUT OF THE SIX THEY COMMITTED,
FOUR OF THEM WERE BUTCHERS WITH
MACHETES AND BURIED IN SHALLOW
GRAVES.
THE FAMILIES CAN'T IDENTIFY AND
CAN FIND THEM.
WE NEED THAT SUPPORT FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
HE IS SUPPORTING OUR ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS.
WE CAN ALSO USE SOME FUNDING.
>> Kimberly: THE PRESIDENT
TACKLING THIS ISSUE HEAD-ON,
GREG, AND DOUBLING DOWN.
HE FACED CRITICISM.
HE SAID HE FACED REBUKE FOR
CALLING AND IDENTIFYING
SPECIFICALLY GANG MEMBERS FROM
MS-13, CALLING THEM ANIMALS.
HE REPEATED THAT TODAY.
HAS SOME EVIDENCE TO BACK IT UP
FROM THE LOCAL AUTHORITIES.
>> Greg: POLITICALLY, THIS IS
A BIG WIN FOR HIM.
IN THIS ISSUE, TRUMP'S DANCEABLE
REGISTER.
FOR HIM, MS-13 STANDS FOR "MUST
STOP."
FOR DEMOCRATS IT STANDS FOR
MISUNDERSTOOD.
THE MORE HE SHOWS THE CONTRAST,
THE BETTER IT IS BECAUSE THE
MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS,
CONTINUALLY WITH TRUMP THEY GET
BOGGED DOWN IN LANGUAGE, AND
THEY ALWAYS LOSE.
THEY ARE SO WORRIED ABOUT THE
WORDS, AND IT REVEALS LOPSIDED
PRIORITIES.
YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WORRIED
ABOUT JOBS, TERROR, NORTH KOREA,
GANGS.
MEANWHILE, YOU HAVE ANOTHER SIDE
THAT'S CONCERNED THAT HE CALLS
GANG MEMBERS ANIMALS.
IMAGINE YOUR HOUSE BEING ON FIRE
AND YOUR NEIGHBORS ARE
COMPLAINING THAT THE FIRE
ENGINES ARE TOO LOUD.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS.
DEMOCRATS WORRYING ABOUT WHAT TO
CALL GANG MEMBERS ARE NEIGHBORS
THING HEY, COULD YOUR FIRE
ENGINES KEEP IT DOWN WHILE THE
HOUSE BURNS?
>> Kimberly: CAN YOU IMAGINE?
THREE ALARMS HERE FOR MS-13.
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE.
I SAW YOU REACTING TO THE
STATISTICS IN TERMS OF NUMBER OF
HOMICIDES AND THE HEINOUS NATURE
OF THE CRIMES THEY COMMIT.
>> Dana: I TALKED TO A FORMER
PROSECUTOR TODAY WHO DID A LOT
OF THESE CASES, ESPECIALLY IN
MARYLAND, WHO SAID HE THINKS OF
MS-13 AS THE MAFIA OF OUR
GENERATION.
ONE OF THE WAYS THEY HAVE GONE
AFTER THEM IS LIKE THEY USED TO
DO WITH THE MOB, WHICH IS RICO.
I ASKED, WHAT LAWS, THE
PRESIDENT SAID TODAY WE NEED
CONGRESS TO DO SOMETHING, WHAT
DO YOU THINK CONGRESS COULD DO
THE GOOD HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT?
HE SAID HE DOES BELIEVE THE LAX
BORDERS OF THE HUGE PROBLEM
BECAUSE OF THE ABILITY TO
REGENERATE AND THEY ARE
RECRUITING AT YOUNGER AND
YOUNGER AGES.
THIS BRUTALITY, HE SAID IT'S
ALMOST ISIS-LIKE THE KILLING,
AND IT IS RATCHETING UP AND
GETTING WORSE.
HE ALSO SAID MS-13 WAS IN ABOUT
TEN STATES IN 2005.
BY THE LATE 2000s IN ALL 50
STATES.
THE THING, I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BRING ATTENTION TO
IT.
CONNELL McSHANE WHEN HE WAS
DOING REPORTING FOR US TODAY,
THERE'S A LOCAL DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESS MEANT WHO IS NOT
INVITED TO TODAY'S MEETING.
I THINK THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
HE SAID HE WOULD HAVE GONE IF HE
HAD BEEN INVITED.
WHY NOT TRY TO CO-OPT SOME OF
THEM, DEMOCRATS, SO THAT YOU CAN
MAKE IT A BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
THESE PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE FUN OF
THE PRESIDENT FIRST THING
ANIMALS, THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THEIR OWN POLITICS ON THAT SIDE.
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM, YOU NEED DEMOCRATS.
>> Kimberly: GOOD EVENT OF.
IT COULD BE EVEN BETTER.
MS-13 ON LONG ISLAND ALONE.
THE BACKDROP, THE PRESIDENT THAT
SECURE OUR BORDERS, PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
SOMEONE SAID YOU CAN'T PROTECT
THE COMMUNITY UNTIL YOU SECURE
THE BORDER.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THAT WIDE
VIEW.
THEY DO REGENERATE.
THE CONTRAST BETWEEN THE FOLKS
YELLING ABOUT THE ANIMALS
COMMENT IS THAT THE PRESIDENT
WANTS THE RULE OF LAW VERSUS
LAWLESSNESS.
HE WANTS BORDERS VERSUS OPEN
BORDERS.
HE BELIEVES MERIT-BASED
IMMIGRATION IS BETTER THAN THE
RUSSIAN ROULETTE OF WHO IS
COMING, WHY ARE THEY COMING.
THIS PRESIDENT IDENTIFIES
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPOSE THE LEFT
AND THE INSANITY THEY PURSUE.
CATCH AND RELEASE, SANCTUARY
CITIES.
MS-13 IS THAT EXAMPLE, AND
EVERYONE KNOWS IT.
IT'S A REAL PROBLEM FOR REAL
PEOPLE IN THEIR LIVES.
I THINK HE HAS HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD.
>> Kimberly: UNFORTUNATE
POSITION, THE LEFT, RICHARD,
THOUGH THEY ARE DEFENDING KIND
OF THESE LAWLESS CRIMINALS.
NOW THE PROLIFERATION HAS SPREAD
TO ALL 50 STATES.
SEEMS PERFECTLY APPROPRIATE
BECAUSE THEY ARE DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS IN TERMS OF CRIME,
RACKETEERING, MURDERS THEY CARRY
OUT.
>> Richard: HERE IS MY TAKE ON
THIS.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE THE
ANIMALS COMMENT, HE COMPLAINED
HE WAS TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT, AND
HE WAS.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING WITH
NANCY PELOSI NOW IS TAKING HER
OUT OF CONTEXT.
HER ARGUMENT WITH A LARGER
NARRATIVE ABOUT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT'S RHETORIC ON
IMMIGRATION OVERALL AND HOW THIS
ANIMAL COMMENT BLEEDS INTO THAT
LARGER NARRATIVE.
IT WAS NOTHING TO DO WITH MS-13.
IF YOU ASK ANY DEMOCRAT ON
CAPITOL HILL, THEY WOULD SAY
YES, MS-13 IS HEINOUS.
THEY ARE AWFUL AND THAT'S WHY WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE GANGS LIKE
THAT IN THIS COUNTRY DON'T
SPREAD.
YOU HAVE TO SEPARATE MS-13 FROM
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO, FROM THE
DREAMERS, YOU HAVE TO
SEPARATE --
LET ME FINISH.
I THINK ABOUT THE MOTHER WHO
LEFT GUATEMALA OR NICARAGUA OR
EL SALVADOR, THE THREE MOST
DANGEROUS COUNTRIES ON EARTH.
WALKED 3,000 MATH WITH ALL THEIR
BELONGINGS AND THEIR CHILDREN TO
SEEK FREEDOM AND THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
THEY ARE NOWHERE NEAR WHAT MS-13
IS.
>> Greg: IT IS WHAT THEY ARE
REFERRING TO.
>> Richard: YOU CANNOT
CONFLATE.
>> Pete: SHE PURPOSELY
CONFLATED.
WHEN TRUMP SAID MS-13       MS 1
WHEN TRUMP SAID MS-13       MS
WHEN TRUMP SAID MS-13       MS H
WHEN TRUMP SAID MS-13       MS T
WHEN TRUMP SAID MS-13       MS E
WHEN TRUMP SAID MS-13       MS Y
ARE ANIMALS, --
THEY WANT TO MAKE PEOPLE THINK
HE IS RACIST.
>> Richard: YOU JUST TWISTED A
WHOLE BUNCH OF THINGS TO CREATE
ALTERNATIVE FACTS.
>> Kimberly: NO, YOU DIDN'T.
>> Richard: WHAT NANCY PELOSI
WAS TRYING TO SAY WAS THE
PREDATOR RHETORIC OVERALL.
THE RHETORIC LEADS TO THE
PROBLEM.
>> Greg: THE ARGUMENT YOU ARE
USING IS THAT IT REALLY DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT TRUMP SAID NOW.
IT'S WHAT HE SAID THEN.
LAND ALSO ONE COULD ARGUE WHAT
HE MEANT BACK THEN WAS EXACTLY
WHAT HE MEANT NOW BUT HE DID IT
IN A SLOPPY WAY.
THE FACT IS THIS ARGUMENT CANNOT
WORK.
I DIDN'T ROB A BANK BUT MAY BE
IN THE PAST I MIGHT HAVE, SO
HE'S PROBABLY GUILTY.
IF HE'S NOT GUILTY NOW, HE WAS
PROBABLY GUILTY THEN.
IT'S AN ILLOGICAL ARGUMENT.
YOU CAN'T SAY, AND I USE THIS
ANALOGY BEFORE.
WHEN YOU FIND A HATE CRIME AND
IT TURNS OUT TO BE FALSE, THE
LEFT SAYS WELL, IT'S FALSE HERE
BUT IT COULD BE TRUE SOMEWHERE
ELSE.
IT'S ACTUALLY A DEFLECTION.
ADMITTING TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
>> Kimberly: YOU HEAR ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY AND YOU CARE ABOUT
PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO GO TO WORK
AND TAKE THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL,
WHY WOULD YOU TAKE THE SIDE OF
PEOPLE COMING IN COMMITTING
HEINOUS CRIMES, MURDERS.
>> Greg: WHY ARE YOU IN MS-13?
>> Richard: I AM NOT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: WHY ARE YOU DENYING
THIS?
>> Richard: WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT HE IS TAKING NANCY PELOSI
OUT OF CONTEXT.
>> Greg: NO.
SHE TOOK HIM OUT OF CONTEXT, AND
HE RESPONDED.
>> Richard: BY TAKING HER OUT
OF CONTEXT.
PLAYED THIS INCORRECTLY FROM A
STRATEGIC STANDPOINT.
THIS IS A COMMUNITY YOU WOULD
THINK WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE IT IF
THE DEMOCRATS THAT WE UNDERSTAND
YOU ARE NOT LIKE THEM BUT WE ARE
GOING TO PROTECT YOU BY GOING
AFTER THEM.
THE STRATEGY ON THIS DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> Pete: JUST ADMIT ONE TIME
THE PRESIDENT MIGHT BE RIGHT.
>> Richard: WHEN THE
PRESIDENT'S RIGHT, I WILL GIVE
HIM CREDIT.
BUT HE IS CONFLATING REGULAR
IMMIGRANTS --
>> Kimberly: WE ARE GOING TO
AGREE TO DISAGREE ON THAT.
WATCH THIS HEATED EXCHANGE
BETWEEN THE HEAD OF I.C.E. AND A
DEMOCRATIC CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSWOMAN.
>> WOULD LOVE TO PAINT
IMMIGRANTS AS CRIMINALS.
THAT'S NOT THE COMPLETE FACTS.
IT MAKES ME SICK TO MY STOMACH
TO KEEP HEARING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, PAINTING THE BROAD STROKE
IN THE PICTURE AS THOUGH THESE
ARE FOLKS WHO ARE COMING HERE TO
DO HARM.
>> NO ONE ON THIS PANEL IS
ANTI-IMMIGRANT.
WE ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ENFORCING THE LAW THAT YOU
ENACTED.
TO SAY WE ARE ANTI-IMMIGRANT IS
WRONG.
>> Kimberly: PEOPLE TAKING
OFFENSE.
THEY ARE NOT SAYING THEY ARE
ANTI-IMMIGRANT.
THEY ARE FOR UPHOLDING THE LOST
ARE ON THE BOOKS.
HOW IS IT ANTI-IMMIGRANT?
HOW IS IT RACIST TO ENFORCE THE
LAW AND ENSURE PUBLIC SAFETY?
>> Greg: IT IS CONFLATION.
WE HAVE BEEN IN A SITUATION WE
WILL TALK ABOUT ISLAMIC
TERRORISM AND PEOPLE ACCUSE OF
ISLAMAPHOBIA.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT ISLAM.
I AM TALKING ABOUT TERRORISTS
WHO HAPPEN TO BE ISLAMIC.
ISLAMIC TERRORISTS.
I DIDN'T SAY ISLAM.
PEOPLE GO, YOU ARE ISLAMAPHOBIC.
IT'S THE SAME ARGUMENT.
HOW DARE YOU COME OUT AGAINST
GANGS FLAPPING TO BE A SPECIFIC
MINORITY.
YOU DON'T LIKE THAT MINORITY.
NO, YOU ACTUALLY GUILTY OF DOING
THAT.
IF YOU HEAR MS-13 AND HERE
INNOCENT IMMIGRANT, THAT'S ON
YOU, NOT ANYBODY ELSE.
>> Kimberly: ONE OF THE
DEFINITIONS IN THE DICTIONARY IN
ANIMAL IS AN INHUMAN PERSON,
BRITISH OR BEASTLIKE PERSON.
>> Greg: MY NICKNAME IN THE
GYM.
A LOT OF ATHLETES, WRESTLERS.
>> Dana: IN THE HEARING WITH
THE CONGRESSWOMAN, THERE WAS NO
OTHER CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS ARE
THERE TO HIM.
>> Pete: I TESTIFIED IN FRONT
OF CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES
WHERE THERE IS NOBODY THERE.
>> Richard: WHEN IT COMES TO
IMMIGRATION PASSING REFORM,
BECAUSE OUR LAWS WERE MADE IN
1984, CONGRESS IS MISSING IN
ACTION.